good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday also
known as the eve of friday hope
everyone's having a great day
hey jax hey thursday's always you know a
good one someone can complain on a
thursday so much hope in the air yes so
much to look forward to
i was talking to brew this morning and
our favorite time of the week we live
five days for the two days where we can
sleep in together and so i was like brew
one more sleep till it's our favorite
time of the week and he's like mom go do
your thing mom go do your thing bring
home that coin mom yeah he's like you
gotta put kibble on the table boys gotta
eat get to work i said brew i love how
you understand how it works i hope
everyone had an amazing day enjoyed
yesterday's episode which i thought to
be particularly hilarious that's so
funny you keep saying that no like i
don't want to jinx or anything but like
we're killing we're gonna roll we are
maybe we should make this our career
today's no exception jax like we're
gonna kill it today too oh my god look
at you in your positive attitude you're
now four for four on days of positivity
you know what i'm so glad that you
brought that up
because
there's something i want to share
um and i feel like if i stand on the
podcast like i have to be kept kept
accountable but like ever since monday
i've just had this like a whole new
outlook
on life and just like i have so many
things coming up i have my tour coming
up which i'll be announcing date soon
you know simon's wedding where like
literally the entire kardashian family
will be at i'm going on a trip with
brian and i just have all these things
coming up and i want to be like the best
version of myself both physically and
emotionally and mentally and i feel like
i'm really getting
on a good like track with the mental
like i've been so positive lately right
yeah it's the yom kippur effect
and because i was gonna say to what do
we owe this pleasure i just feel like
i'm coming out of like my summer
slump
like i was just like drinking every
night like eating like [ __ ] not taking
care of my body like i feel like i've
been drinking so much water like i don't
know if you've noticed like almost every
day there's water in my love island
bottle like that's a really big deal for
me you guys that's the intended effect
that's why they have them on the show
like i think they would dehydrate out
there otherwise
no and like something about this little
straw like
slurpee thing like makes drinking water
kind of fun look at you no i know jackie
i'm telling you like i've lost two
pounds because i've been working i've
been walking to work every day because
like now that i'm getting back on tour
like i cannot be like so as out of shape
as i am
whilst on the road and you know at the
end of last tour like i got so snatched
like maybe that'll happen again um so i
don't know i'm just feeling like this is
a new me and i encourage you
find a new version of yourself you're
gonna like what you see i guarantee it
okay so
do you have any tips or tricks for you
know for getting in the headspace that's
the hardest part about it like i just
feel like honestly like you have to hit
rock bottom like and i feel like i hit
rock bottom like a week ago like i just
woke up in one particular
one per day particularly hungover and i
just been like acting like an animal the
night before and i was like you know
what like
we got it's time to grow up you know so
i think it's really all about like how
you
see your life and how you see yourself
that's what i would say this is like
just we're gonna have to put this
podcast in a different category no
inspirational it's literally
education whatever that category is
there's an education category and i'm
teaching you how to be your best self
all you have to do is join my mlm ten
thousand dollars to buy in and i'll see
you at the meeting
what are you selling
positivity and you actually can't put a
price on it you actually sound like a
pyramid scheme no not to be confused
with an mlm join my team full of boss
babes
we're selling positivity and we're
changing lives and you can be a boss
babe from your own home
well now that's something well if it's
from your own home
so yeah don't mind me just being like
positive queen over here that's so
beautiful i mean
we love to see it we love to see change
oh god oh god so much positivity like
raining out of my mouth i'd love to see
change
oh my god okay you guys so jackie and i
were in the street yesterday and if
you're watching on youtube or if you're
actually if you're listening to the
podcast there's like this hand gesture
that is like viral on tick tock i think
it's like big in the gaming community
when like you're shy or like you're
meeting people on the internet i don't
know you like put your fingers together
and you make this like signal that's
like i'm shy and it's become like a
thing on tick tock like a dance move
it's like
like
jackie did it to me in the street
yesterday and when i tell you i was
shocked honey i was in tears almost
because first of all how do you know
that
so i know it because and did you know
what it meant when you did it no i
didn't know it meant i'm shy but i
remember seeing a meme that was like an
emoji
of like a face a blushing face with two
fingers pointing at each other and i can
you know also surmise that's in some
tick tock dances i've seen addison go
like this yeah
um and just the question that you asked
me i forget what it was but like this
was the only logical answer and you also
made the accompanying like facial
expression it's like this pout like
i'm shy and i was really shocked to hear
you say that i'm not gonna lie i mean i
said it with my whole chest you did and
like it stopped me dead in my tracks
like on the street like i was floored
the house town yeah
shocked
i i'm i
i don't know what to tell you every day
we're getting closer and closer to you
getting back on tick tock i'm telling
you
no i'm telling you
i'm farther and farther away even though
i saw that there was some love for ac
out there because you know my tic toc
was just a counselor snitch fan page and
was run by ac um
and people clearly really related to
that and they miss her and i you know
love for ac like warms my heart so much
because like she is
so close to your heart everything to me
she's really a piece of you if you come
for ac like you're coming for me ac by
the way is american camper and
if you need a background on the camper
saga ask your local toaster ask your
local toaster exactly um
so it was nice to see everyone like
talking about how they missed ac on the
talk and like please come back but i'm
sorry but everything that you send me
just makes me feel even stronger about
my decision okay fine you know what like
me trying to get you on tick tock is
like you trying to get me to read a
historical fiction novel i'm useless and
disappointing speaking of
last night i was watching outlander and
then i switched to beverly hills and i
was like i can't go back to outlander
one i'm i'm so nervous all the time that
i'm gonna see something and two
there's so many moments where it's not
good like they're constantly on the run
everything's always going wrong like i
need shows where there are some wins for
the main character some stability it
can't always be bad like i need to see
my faves winning sometimes no that's
true and so i was like i don't want to
go back it's like puts me and brew on
edge too like he hears a small sound he
starts barking i'm like i can't do this
to brew i think i should go back to
reading because i'll sleep better when i
read and i
it's just better for me but then i could
not
find anything i wanted to read like i
was
completely at a loss i sort of wanted to
read another tessa bailey book i sort of
wanted to read like a a silly rom-com
book similar to it it happened one
summer just to be like transported you
know nothing crazy don't have to think
too hard i couldn't really find anything
and then also i would see some titles
i'm like this looks too stupid so then i
would go to something that looks more
serious i'm like this looks too serious
so many looks
exactly
i wound up starting
jane eyre
oh my god
i can't i can't i've never read it it's
such a classic for a reason you know i
read the description it sounds like a a
great novel and you know scores of
readers have really fallen in love with
jane over the course yeah over many
centuries scores scores of centuries too
scores of centuries scores of readers
and
i'm reading jane eyre everyone
and i'm just pivoting completely i'm
reading the sequel to the tessa bailey
fix her up i can't remember what it's
called
what is the book called
whatever it's not that great
you should try jane eyre no but i'm so
happy for you i'm just i needed to pick
something and i just i'm glad that i
picked something no and so far i'm five
percent in and
you're happy with your choice i'm happy
with it i'm fine with my choice i just
needed to make it just because it's the
one you got i just needed to make a
choice i feel that um but beverly hills
was on last night and i did catch up
with the episode from the previous week
because i hadn't seen it and i have a
lot to say in our tv recap so i'm very
much looking forward to breaking that
down with you sister me too and some
news just dropped this morning um about
tom about tom
it's about tom it's literally about tom
and so we'll talk about that fifth and
final story leading into the tv recap it
also just like makes everything from
last night shown in a completely
different light yeah
so i guess i mean you have any downtown
updates that you want to share i watched
a ton of downtime like me and ben are
officially separated on the matter it
always happens it had to happen like ben
is you know he went to a concert last
night tonight he's going to a dinner
like i spend my nights in bed on the
weeknights and i like to enjoy my shows
so if ben's not going to be home in bed
then i'm just gonna have to take matters
into my own hands and i finished season
four last night and it's just so good i
mean i'm still like waiting with baited
breath to find out what happened with
this mystery man
but she did burn the house down quite
literally and that was probably one of
the funniest things ever she literally
almost burned down like the entire
palace but thankfully it was just
contained to her bedroom thanks to mr
barrow um
so yeah i'm i don't really have any
updates until like i find out what the
[ __ ] happened to michael gregson
okay i could tell you but i won't no no
no it's much too good for children yeah
stay tuned
i will
okay i think we should get into
everything yeah except like i've really
been noticing because i've been so
immersed in the downton
landscape that i've really started to
talk like differently
no that's like australian but um like an
accent yeah just words words like yeah
that'll happen
like if i'm
if i love you instead i'll be like i
love you i'll always say like
not always but like recently i've
started saying
i love you so very much
so very much
and that's beautiful i haven't heard
that from you
well because i don't tell you i love you
that's why
you mean to me and you think that's
right
cause you make fun of me what do i make
you just made fun of me you
just made fun of me
i don't think that i did so maybe if you
were kinder
i would tell you that so you don't like
but i would tell you that i love you
very much no i do love you but i don't
feel the need to tell you when you're
making fun of me mocking my passions
if we're going to talk about mocking
passions i don't mock your power we're
going to start i just ignore them we're
going to start somewhere else i don't
ignore your passion jackie i just
pretend they don't exist and that hurts
too
and it's still we should talk about that
and it still doesn't take away from me
letting you know how dearly i love you
well jackie i love you so very much
very very much
what they don't even say that yes they
do instead of like
like i love you so much you're like
i love you so very much they don't tell
each other they love each other it
doesn't happen often but when it does
it's quite beautiful and impactful and
influential on me okay whatever and
instead of being like yeah i'm okay with
that i'm always like i'm very pleased
you should be pleased i'm very very
pleased and then when you're in the
shower are you like can you pass me your
lady [ __ ] so no
but when i see ben i'm like get the [ __ ]
out of my way my lord thank you
nice except like i think in our house
ben would be like a foot man and i'm the
damage accountant and it's his lordship
which i don't like his lordship and his
lady ship is what they called yeah but
who do you call melod
would would like a footman have called
matthew crowley that
no his lordship
because we're calling him mr matthew
anyway it's confusing no the names make
no sense yeah okay let's get into the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and today's
episode is brought to you by relief band
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more so get you
a girl so you could do both jackie loves
the relief ben for her morning sickness
and i love my relief ben for the other
type of morning sickness a hangover the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed the technology was developed over
20 years ago and is used in hospitals to
relieve nausea but patients now through
the relief band are available to use the
technology so again it's perfect if you
get sick in cars or on boats you have
anxiety pregnancy morning sickness it's
so easy you just strap on the the band
doesn't you don't even feel it you
forget it's on and it just immediately
gets rid of your nausea it's a fabulous
magical product as you're getting ready
to take
a road trip hop on your boat or you're
just getting anxious about you know the
world's coming back we've got good news
relief ban has an exclusive offer just
for the toast listeners if you go to
reliefband.com and use the promo code
toast you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping and no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so head to relief
band r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use the promo code toast for
20 off plus free shipping it's a
fabulous fabulous product it's a
fabulous product it provides a lot of
relief for all different kinds of nausea
can't recommend it highly enough
first story exciting news snl lineup is
here and you guys
you guys
it's it's happening so new season will
kick off on october 2nd which by the way
like
i feel like i used to talk so much [ __ ]
on snl like it's still like
doesn't always get get it but during the
pandemic i was well not like the dark
episodes where they were doing it from
home but like once they got back in
studio it really was like a bright spot
in my week like i really enjoyed it so
i'm very much looking forward to it
coming back it for me just depends on
the person hosting of course it has to
be someone that i literally die for and
we've been delivered because the season
kicks off on october 2nd host will be
owen wilson with musical guest casey
musgraves i mean i think that's going to
be incredible yeah i do think owen
wilson is like really random because
like okay owen is the blonde brother
right not luke but just as for luke i
think luke is like the better brother
um why
he have something coming out loki he
stars in oh he does yeah l-o-k-i l-o-k-i
doesn't also taylor swift's ex-boyfriend
yes that's what i associate with loki i
think it is loki me too and then i think
owen is you know a friend of i don't
know this friend of loki casey's
excellent i'm not talking about casey
i'm just talking about the host for like
the season opener seems kind of
lackluster no i think that this is
good but also it's not bad it's not
great it's good owen wilson is a very
good funny actor it's gonna be great now
we're two people in a blender whatever
saving lives
he's a very funny guy so it'll be good i
just thought like star power wise it was
kind of random no no this works for me i
like
i'm not to issue a complaint because i
i'm always complaining have then have
luke and owen wilson like ever been in
the same room or even acknowledge the
fact that they're brothers
definitely really i feel like they don't
know i think they're they're
fine as brothers i just don't think
they're annoying about it
are we annoying about it and we do every
single thing together who do you think
like has like who do you like better
i mean i love luke because of legally
blonde i know but he's literally been in
nothing else i know he's always just
like you know the good boyfriend yeah
but owen is just so funny and some like
the internship and
wedding crashers it's just so good you
know i've never seen wedding crashers
like in full you're missing out honestly
i know but like that good now every time
it's like when we play well i've never
played with you obviously but like when
i play two truths and a lie like with
random people like in college and stuff
i would always be like i've never seen
wedding crashers and like it's like that
thing about me and it was a truth so i
feel like i can't see it now oh i mean
if you need it for that purpose then
then fine you never know when you're
going to be thrown into a game of true
truths and a lot and you always need to
come prepared and i never am
never like it's literally the worst
like
i want to start putting myself taking
myself out of situations they're hella
toxic two truths and a lie because it's
just it's not for me and even i thought
on my wellness retreat like during
orientation like we would have to do
like no we didn't thank god and that's
how i knew it was the right retreat for
me right right i find myself in a
situation where it's like we're playing
two truths and a lie
i'm just removing myself i'm an adult
like i can do what i want well the thing
is i'm gonna step away we don't work in
those types of environments like it's
literally the four of us like there's no
one here so maybe we could play two
truths and a lie later but i think as an
adult a lot of where you get those
torturous icebreakers are when you work
for like corporate companies and you
like team building yeah company off
sites like stupid [ __ ] like that so
probably the last time i did it was like
on birthright oh that's the perfect
place for it but also if i was on birth
right and i i excused myself i was when
it was my turn i was like i'm not
standing for this like i wouldn't have
made any friends so sometimes you do
have to break the ice which is
unfortunate anyways just come prepared
yeah and then it's like you know if
you're trying to make it like funny like
i've on more than one occasion wanted to
be like
and everyone would think it was a lie
like
okay one of my truths is like cuban
junior stuck his finger on my butt when
i was at 16 in a club and then then just
gets like dark so it's really just not a
fun game no no it's not a fun game now
that is an interesting fact about me
it is very interesting it is interesting
back to the story at hand october 9th
snl host
kim kardashian west with musical guest
halsey this is amazing
this is so incredible i never thought
about this happening me neither and it
never occurred to me that she's never
done it or that any of the sisters have
never done it and i think she's gonna be
so good because she's so funny she's so
down and obviously if she's putting
herself in the snl environment she's
willing to go with the flow well yeah
i'm nervous for her because like you
know
kim like hates dancing
you know what i mean like remember that
whole prince concert thing yeah she
hates to dance and i just feel like it's
like a personality thing with her like
she's always in control she's like
always in charge i'm actually nervous
for her like i'm not gonna like i'm not
saying
i'm sure she's nervous too but she's
putting herself out of her comfort zone
she's going to do something new and also
like kim doesn't fail like if she sets
her mind to this it's going to be so
funny that's true also even if she's
like awkward or nervous like she's going
to be so cute like during her monologue
i'm dying i can't wait this is as
exciting probably even a little more
exciting than elon musk honestly by the
way her monologue is going to be great
she's a great speaker she's always going
to conferences i'm not worried about her
monologue at all what i did find
interesting is that she's still going by
kkw on the little index card that said
kim kardashian west the only thing that
could have made this better if is if
connie were the musical guest yeah and
then he has a new album out so it's not
unfathomable or like someone who's like
a part of the kardashian crew you know
because halsey is like very much team
taylor swift
oh you know
no i don't that was my first thought i
don't know
no i'm sure like
i'm sure it'll be fun i'm sure halsey
will jump in some skits and everybody
loves kim and by the way everyone really
loves halsey too it's a great gal yeah
she's a great girl okay she's a great
girl it's going to be historic honestly
and there's they announced more people
yes of course but i just we need to
ruminate on this particular this is why
it's a story of course the first story
and you know what i got
i like went on like a rabbit hole
just thought wise
when they post these cards like who's
writing this like who is the writer the
writer of snl font but maybe it's a font
oh i never thought of that right because
that's a lot of pressure for one hand no
you're saying this one hand has been
working for snl forever like
and what happens after this person you
know passes away yeah or moves on like
what if they want a promotion and
lauren's like i'm sorry there's no more
cards for you to write right like the
card writing industry is dead yeah so
this was just a thought i never thought
of it as a font that's a really good
call i think it's a font because look at
the way all the octobers are the exact
same there's no i mean you're 100 right
i'm like a forensic handwriting and now
chilly
we should get an answer but it's a good
that's a good call okay because then i
thought it would be cool to do like a
whole documentary on this person like i
was thinking like that's something like
vice would do you know yeah and that i
would not watch okay
are we ready to move on from kim i just
wanna i can't overstate it enough so
excited so proud of kim for stepping out
of her comfort zone yeah she always has
control but like she's putting herself
in a situation she doesn't know what's
gonna happen and i'm just so excited for
her me too and you know what else i
actually really like about snl they
don't give us like so oh next january
kim it's in two weeks like agreed and
they only announce like three or four at
a time so we don't get too excited for
something that's more than a month away
i actually really appreciate that okay
then on october 16th we have host rami
malik he will be joined by musical guest
young thug and i will be skipping that
one yeah but i'll have to take the week
off after all the excitement from kim
yeah it'll be too much
and then the following week on october
23rd we have jason sudeikis hosting with
singer brandi carlisle
[ __ ] love brandy carlisle we love a
country music representation um and you
know i'll actually be very interested to
see jason sedegas because if they don't
address like the obvious elephant in the
room harry styles of course
um like i know he has other things going
on like ted lasso sweaty emmys he's like
having this great career moment like
he's also having this like
other thing and i would just love for
them to address it i just feel like the
jason sudeikis stands like ted lasso
stands like really don't
think about the harry styles piece like
they're two totally different groups of
people yes but then the the people who
live in the real world who do who are
not like up jason siddique is his butt
like when i hear jason sedakis i'm like
harry styles but you're up harry styles
is but no i'm not just because he
follows me on instagram jackie i would
say you're in that i can't believe you
made me bring that up you're in the camp
of people who are up harry styles but
i'm really there's people who are up
jason sudeikis's butt and the
the twain never shall meet i just want
to say i'm really not uh perry styles
but like compared to the average
american
i think you are no
not like no shade no no probably
compared to the average american like i
might be in his crack
no by the way i'm not taking any slight
offense to it at all i'm saying like
actually i'm really not like the biggest
like harry styles fan like yes do i feel
connected to him because he follows me
on instagram yes i do um but i don't
know if i'm gonna go see him on tour
like i'm not like so far up his ass like
you've already seen him
yeah cause like
you went to his tour
no i didn't you did with the snatcher we
went to the today show
that's even crazier the today's show
invited pets for people who are up his
bus jackie that was a work event that
today's show invited me okay you and the
snatcher went to see harry styles i
believe yeah like a million years ago
okay like and you had a one direction
poster hanging in your dorm oh by the
way i'm fully up the ass of one
direction i not even i'm so far off yes
i'm coming out of their throat who's
your favorite member of one direction
i'd have to think about that but
probably louis
okay no it's harry obviously but like i
just like currently like i'm not
and i don't even like i'm not like i
don't know why you're [ __ ]
gaslighting me like i'm not guessing i'm
just being very direct no but you're
like you are trying to convince me that
i am a harry styles fan i'm trying to
show you that you are but i'm letting
you know like i'm really not i don't
even know that much of his music that
isn't like
super popular like i know sign of the
times okay
i know
um
watermelon sugar oh of course everyone
knows that song you know just give me a
second i wish i could pull out my
spotify like like data and let you know
like how little i listen but that's not
saying i don't like harry styles i love
him like of course he's so cute but like
i'm not trying to be offensive but like
okay watermelon sugar sure adore you i
don't think i know that song i think you
do sing it i don't know how it goes but
it's like it's ever like the title is
everywhere okay play it for a second but
then
oh yeah of course
okay
falling
falling i'm falling i keep on falling no
no remember i tried to sing this song on
the show the other day and you were
falling into fall i'm falling
i mean i have a horrible voice you know
this song
oh
that was not what you say i tried my
best
okay
then there's um
golden
yeah like i
i don't know why this is like becoming a
thing like i like harry styles for sure
but like i'm not up his butt i think
it's very normal to see jason sudeikis
and think of harry styles that's the
original point i was trying to make and
now that we've gone down this rabbit
hole this episode would only be made
better if it was jason as host harry as
musical guest oh my god that would
make my life that would be crazy i mean
they might have to start co-parenting so
like it's better that they just get on
the right foot 100
okay so that's all the snl hosting
guests we have so far so they announced
what three or four weeks that's exciting
it's exciting and i like that they don't
like schedule a whole lineup for the
whole year because you know people
change and people come up they come down
someone could be a nobody right now and
famous in november olivia rodrigo like
that's how it happens
so i really um i'm very excited i'm very
excited as well and are you ready for
our next story yeah
um
megan fox and kourtney kardashian are
the new faces of skim's cotton
collection so and they are brilliant
beating up the internet
it was a sickening photo shoot i mean
all the skins merchandising is gorgeous
but this was just like a sick photo
shoot like two like snatched girls like
eating an apple it was gorgeous but also
the sheer concept of it like my god this
is just like the marketing machine that
is a kardashian empire like you can deny
it you can deny it all you want but like
this is proof like they are so [ __ ]
smart
it's twisted how smart they are no it's
twisted these pictures are everything
like and it just like confirms like
megan and courtney are artists
these pictures were probably taken a
while ago too right
they both look so incredible like i'm
buying what they're selling me too and
it really is kim like she's so on
trend even when she had like addison in
the skin yeah pain like
she's just
crushing it no and skims is just like
everything of the sort you know
i like
i always forget that kim even has other
companies like her fragrances and kkw
beauty which is like in the process of a
rebrand but like skims is absolutely
everything and skims is a billion dollar
industry yeah and
these pictures were
so gorgeous flames i loved it i was
shocked i just was not expecting to see
it at all okay but now here's my
question
does she pay them
yes yeah
yeah but like i
i think she pays them like their market
value value price because honestly like
i think that this relationship that
megan fox has had with machine gun kelly
and therefore like thrust into this
kardashian world um has been
like the most attention megan fox has
gotten in years because like she's
always been really really famous but she
has had this weird career where she was
blackballed in 2009 and like
she hasn't really got that many movie
roles anymore so like i think you get
there are multiple ways of getting paid
and i think the attention the press
all of it is a huge
yeah value to megan fox in addition to
that of course you have to pay like a
day rate right i don't think this was
like charity work first no no no no yeah
do you think courtney gets paid no
i think she should i think she should do
she probably does and she probably does
but yeah it's just curious yeah cause
like obviously i would do a skims
campaign for free but
i'm not megan fox i mean like i would
but then i think about like i have to be
in my skins and then i'm like that would
take a lot of money
oh you think yeah i know i i would come
to peace with it for free
just want to meet kim i need at least a
billion dollars i just need to have a
talk with the ceo
totally a billion dollars
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah
jennifer nettles is going to broadway
she is joining the cast of a waitress
following in the footsteps of sarah
bareilles
and catherine mcphee and catherine
mcphee and is it wasn't it um carrie
russell
and
miranda sings no yeah she was in
waitress musical i don't know if she was
the actress
that sara bareilles was but she was in
it so was toddrick okay also the part
has been played by jordan sparks
nicolette robinson shoshanna bean betsy
wolfe and more wow i didn't realize
there had been so many people who played
it if you're like a broadway like fan or
just
like like hearing people who can sing
go to youtube and search show shauna
bean she used to be mine and it's a
video with broadway.com they have like
the studio in times square where people
just like come and sing covers and it is
hands down the most beautiful thing i've
ever heard in my life so i've never seen
waitress in musical i have no idea what
it's about but she used to be mine as my
go-to karaoke song and i'm not gonna lie
like
tears are shed like it's a moment for us
all
and
now i'm like i've got to go see the
musical i've never even seen it also i
was thinking shoshana bean sounds
familiar from greatest showman somehow i
couldn't put it together she recorded
the demo for this is me not the one that
we heard like obviously it was chaos oh
that's so interesting she like was part
of the she's just like a broadway queen
she's like a new york queen and
she's the most incredible voice like
you've ever heard in your life that song
she used to be mine just makes me too
sad it's just so sad
later today like when you have a moment
of peace go to youtube and watch a video
it's and then also they have the same
broadway.com video with katherine mcphee
singing it also really good shashana is
much better but catherine's is also
stunning interesting it's naughty it's
cute that the show always has like a uh
rotating rotating like big star and i
think this country
bro crossover is going to be so exciting
i love jennifer nettles like she is a
true icon yeah what band is she in
sugarland right she was like she's a
band it's like a duo yeah but she also
did some solo stuff i think yes i'll
show you the song with like bon jovi
speaking of the music kelly clarkson's
new christmas single came out today
christmas isn't cancelled just you and i
was listening to you is she talking to
me
yeah no way it's like her fault but no
she's talking about her ex i when i was
when i was listening to it i was like oh
this is like a good like christmas song
for someone who's like is that an elf
with old tweets go to your breakup no
it's just like how
christmas isn't going to be ruined for
her because he's not there right now
you're ruining it's not christmas i have
forgotten that she's like literally
going through such heartbreak right
that's so kelly clarkson write like a
breakup song but make it christmas and
she has a christmas album coming out on
october 15th which is crazy because her
existing christmas album
wrapped in red is the best christmas
album like if i could only listen to one
forever it might have to be that one
it's so [ __ ] good so the fact that
we're getting a sequel we're not worthy
if i could listen to one christmas album
until the end of time it would be like
the glee one
it's so good and you get all the classic
kids right no but i'm saying hers is up
there with like
the best of the best carrie underwood
mariah carey well mariah carey doesn't
actually have a christmas album she just
has the christmas song and she's a
christmas queen yeah i would have to go
through like michael buble would
obviously be you know some people's um
choice i don't know after that whole
michael buble scandal i was never able
to look at him in the same way again
like yeah no things have changed i think
he keeps coming up on my tick tock and
he's like he's doing all these things to
prove he's not a sociopath and i just
know like when the doors are closed like
he's a [ __ ] monster like i just know
it in my boat when your eyes are closed
you see him for what he truly is which
is a monster
literally
um but back to kelly what was this
jennifer oh jennifer so yeah so she's
sugarland of course she sings the iconic
taylor swift written song how could you
do this babe and then also stuck like
glue you and me baby whistle
she's kind of like an icon yes she is
there's one sugarland song that's like
iconic good i don't know if it's even
let me try and find it hold on let me
try and find it too i'm trying to find
it in my like songs but it's like
she also has um a song with bon jovi
could it be still the same
it could be that's what's in my liked
what is the song she has with bon jovi
it's so good jennifer what's her name
who says you can't comment being all
around the world that's a matter of fact
she's a queen like
can we see here on broadway maybe i'll
finally see i really would like to see
also unlove you by jennifer nettles it's
in my heart so it must be good i would
like to see waitress musical i don't
know if i want to see it with jennifer
nettles though like i really would love
to see it with shoshana bean or like
catherine mcphee
well
she's the one you guys i missed
literally
literally okay ready for our next story
but will you promise me you'll watch
that shoshana bean video i actually
can't promise you because like it might
make me too emotional oh my god just
watch it you don't know you guys have to
watch it
no i have to avoid emotional triggers
it's not emotional it's just a beautiful
song no but that song
i find to be particularly sad it is but
like that's why it's so beautiful and
honestly like i think that's gonna
become like my next go-to song like you
know whenever i'm like you know i can
sing and everyone's like claudia is
saying i always sing don't rain on my
parade
i disagree with this no decision trust
me i'll send you a video later of me
singing it like i did karaoke right now
share with the class no no give us a
little bit it's too meaningful to me
give us a sneak peek if it's so
meaningful you can't even sing it like
just on the couch with your sis how are
you going to sing it at a dinner party
well i haven't practiced it like enough
yet but like i will get it to a point
where it's so good
i can't do it yet honestly like it's
i'll make a video and send it to you and
then you'll let me know
okay
okay fine but like nothing and carves
out a person no i'm kidding i'm really
gonna work on it and then i'll send it
to you okay thank you but now i've got
you no i'm done
i don't know
next story if i'm
moniesta no no i'm done yeah it's not
sounding uh
[Music]
excuse me because don't write on my
parade you're ver the claudia version
for me
is is better than
rachel berry like you know how i feel
about it so you're gonna have to really
you know when i get home today i'm gonna
make two videos okay
one don't write on my parade
two shoes see mine and we'll put it to a
vote
okay
i'm
i'm not worried
are you ready for our next story finally
are you going to cut me off and sing
again no i'm just like really like hurt
that you said it didn't sound good
i'm sorry for your want for your go-to
song it's got to be the best of the best
like i'm not going to let you get away
with mediocrity
fine
are you ready for our next story
no no yeah i am okay cool
linda evangelista is suing over cosmetic
procedure that she says left her
brutally disfigured and deeply depressed
the former supermodel said to my
followers who have wondered why i have
not been working while my peers careers
have been thriving the reason is that i
was brutally disfigured by zeltique's
coolsculpting procedure which did the
opposite of what it promised she posted
to her instagram she claimed the
treatment increased not decreased her
fat cells and left her permanently
deformed even after undergoing two
painful unsuccessful corrective
surgeries oh my god she added that she
has been left as what the media
described as
unrecognizable this is really surprising
yeah also because cool spots like an
outpatient
it's not like a invasive procedure so to
have results that leave you like
disfigured
when it's like a
app some people don't even see results
from cold spotlight yeah that's mostly
what i've heard about cool spots right
it's like a waste of time and money yeah
yeah so i i'm not sure but like that is
really sad and also like just a good
warning for other people yeah you know
i don't really think i believe in cool
spot even though i do know someone who
got a cool spot on their neck and it
like looked amazing
what was their next situation before
like big neck
i thought about doing cool spa a few
times i know i remember i thought that
my you know particular ailments would
could be solved but then enough people
told me that it's a waste of time it's a
hoax and it's like a little painful too
no it's incredibly painful and i thought
at worst it was just a waste but it
seems like at worst it could do the
opposite of the intended infect so yeah
like unfortunately like things like that
like if you want to get all the fat
removed like you just have to get
liposuction like you there's no magic
machine
unless you're going in for surgery
that's going to get rid of it trust me
i've tried yeah it's really true
so or like you're going to die diet and
exercise which is going to be a no for
me but there are still like other things
though that
you can't target
with diet and exercise like if you just
right
that's why like so many people just get
like liposuction in the stomach so the
stomach's like always flat and then like
yeah anyway she said i'm moving forward
to rid myself of my shame and going
public with my story i'm so tired of
living this way i would like to walk out
my door with my head held high despite
not looking like myself any longer come
on linda do it we're here for you do it
like you're a queen an icon to be honest
i don't really know who luna evangelista
is but like her name sounds familiar
she's one of the like cindy crawford
yeah exactly i think she doesn't get out
of bed in the morning for less than ten
thousand dollars that was her who said
that that is a really fabulous mantra to
have and that was before inflation too
much it's probably like 30 000.
yeah i mean it wasn't that long ago but
yeah inflation inflation is real
inflation's pretty high so that's really
sad but like you know what you're a
queen i hope that this feels like you've
breaking broken the shackles of your
shame
and your queen and like live your life
yeah agreed and it was linda evangelista
who said that got it
are you ready for a fifth and final
story that's gonna lead into our tv
recap
no i'm not hold on you're not ready
we got to get the band together back
together band practice
okay now
it's the final story
[Music]
she used to be mine
[Applause]
how about for your dinner party trick
you sing the final story
i should bring my triangle with me
everywhere i go it's the thank you so
much for having me at your beautiful
home i've had an amazing time tonight
this is the final story by jackie and
claudia ashrae
it's the final
story
stunning i gotta work in the arrangement
but that's a good idea yeah also like i
like how we're worried about this when
i've literally been invited to one
dinner party in the last like six years
yeah but you know it's just like two
truths in the lie you always have to be
prepared always our fifth and final
story is that tom girardi was spotted
leaving a two-hour lunch with a friend
at an upscale restaurant and the paps
got him packed they asked him the
question that's on everyone's mind did
erica know anything and he stated i
think she does
so here's the thing i watch the video
and he's definitely like weird like he's
not them actually
he didn't feel like that different than
like he's always been like an old man
who like talks slow and like
is weird
but
they're saying he has early onset
dementia blah blah blah
alzheimer's
so if they ask you a question you're not
going to know who erica is
i mean it depends on what stage he's at
but also like
the answer to his question was in like
the wrong tense based on the question
that was asked did she know anything and
he said i think she does yeah now she
knows everything thanks
oh that's an interesting call i mean
this doesn't bode well for erica this is
like the first time anyone's even gotten
a word out of tom's mouth right and he's
really the only one who would know in
his heart and soul like if she knew but
of course like they're also going
through a divorce so of course he's not
going to have her back
which is just even more
surprising after last night's episode
where she really like was acting like
the concerned ex-wife like put all the
drama aside like this man deserves
better than what he's getting and if you
watch the video fast forward the next
day he threw her under the bus that's
his version of he had two bodyguards
with him who were like telling the
paparazzi like turn your camera off turn
the camera off like no no no and tom
like stood by and like wanted to talk
and he like thought for a second
and the paparazzi was like i'm not
turning the camera off tom wants to
answer me and he did like tom didn't
move
tom had something to say
well that doesn't surprise me because i
mean obviously he's his ship is going
down there's no stopping what he did but
he's also mad at erica she dropped him
off at work and then left
high and dry and probably in what is
going to be the worst time of his life
and he wants to get back at her and
she's you know in vegas opening up sushi
samba and she's on tv and like even
though she's obviously going through a
hard time compared to the
uh living facility that tom's in with
his black eye you know he's wants to
take her down with him no he's like this
is [ __ ] so i don't believe really
what he has to say but it's just like it
just underscores even more so how last
night of course like erica having
concern for tom's well-being is just
feels so misplaced when it's like
it's not that she said you want to know
who your real friends are get old and go
broke that's not what happened here get
old go broke and steal from some of the
most most vulnerable members of our
society yeah exactly then you'll know
who your real friends are because who
would want to be [ __ ] friends with
you totally and i would say if i was
your friend and i left you because you
took advantage of the most vulnerable
members of our society i would feel good
about knowing you're being your friend
100 i would feel as though i'm the good
person in this situation honestly after
last night's episode and we'll dive into
the tv recap in one second i just really
felt like i can't keep up with what's
going on anymore like first of all the
erica stuff is so frustrating like we're
all just like sitting around the table
acting like erica's not there's not a
good amount of evidence to prove that
erica knew about these atrocious crimes
like so we're all just going to pretend
that doesn't exist and then there's this
like moronic [ __ ] going on between like
dorit and garcelle and like and lisa and
garcelle and it's just so stupid like i
actually could not keep up with the
other side of the table last night no
agreed and it turned into what seemed to
be a nice dinner but i
i'm so glad garcelle called out what
they continue to do which is like be
honest be honest be honest oh and i'm
helping you i'm gonna throw you under
the bus but it's for your own good okay
so let's dive into the tv recap i feel
like now's as good a time as ever and
the tv recap is brought to you by
fastgrowingtrees.com
skip the big box stores and head to
fastgrowingtrees.com the world's largest
online nursery because actually the fall
is the best time to plant trees and i
don't know if you guys knew this but
yesterday was the first day of fall
there's no more waiting in line messy
cars digging through lackluster
selections just go to
fastgrowingtrees.com and choose from
thousands of varieties of trees shrubs
and plants expertly curated to thrive in
your area and deliver to your door in
one or two days whether you're looking
for shade privacy fruit trees or just
added color for your yard every plant is
shipped with a well-developed root
system ready to explode with new growth
coming come spring
so this is fabulous like if you're a
plant mom you have a yard
hustling back and forth to the store and
like getting dirt all over your car is
just no way to live and fast-growing
trees is just fabulous selection the
delivery is amazing and the plants
arrive in tip-top shape
and now through november 30th go to
fastgrowingtrees.com toast you'll get 15
off so that's fastgrowingtrees.com
toast for 15
off um
fastgrowingfastgrowingtrees.com toast
check it out that's a new sponsor and
for all of our um
plant moms check it out yeah no that's a
great tip thanks claude okay i'm sorry
what were you saying so yourself so okay
i guess we'll talk about dorit and
garcelle and their tiff and lucyrena
just like butting in i can't stop oh my
god and i can't stand her and everything
just comes back to denise for me i'm
sorry always same for garcelle and i
just she gives voice to so many of the
two the voiceless
yes and so many of the things that i'm
thinking and feeling like even when
sutton you know kyle literally did the
same thing did the same thing and is
telling her she's helping her like i'm
sorry no you're not i i know i'm not on
the show but you're not helping anything
and you're not letting sutton get her
point across i'm glad sudden and erica
have just reached this like
i don't want to talk to you i don't want
to talk to you erica is so [ __ ]
dismissive and rude and for someone
who's being it's not that like
they keep acting like oh it's just her
husband lost her money and you know that
it's just
like it's more than that collateral
damage like it's so much more than that
what tom is being accused of is awful
awful awful and for the women to sit
around and pretend like that doesn't
have anything there is erica it's just
like what it's more honest over the fact
that they were married for 20 years and
she divorced him the week before all of
this came out like how are those two
things not related of course they are
and honestly like eric is so mad at
sutton for calling her a liar but in
response to being called a liar she has
called sutton small-minded miss small
town she's threatened her so it's like
we're
not even here like it's so stupid and
honestly if i was sutton i would be so
mad at the other women a hundred percent
especially like because it's in light of
you know how they treated denise for um
what she may or may have not done with
brandy in her personal life where is
that energy own it answer the questions
be honest with erica no and
what is lisa reyna's tagline
um
because i had a thought while watching
last night's episode
because it's such a contradiction yes
we're made for talking i don't know hold
on
lip lip it's something about her lips
lisa in a tagline
these lips
oh my lips are legendary and they will
never gloss over the truth and when it
really should have been my lips are
legendary and they will never gloss over
the truth unless it's about erica and
tom stealing millions of dollars from
orphans and widows no i mean they will
never gloss over the truth
when it comes to denise wait for
everything else
for everything else they are completely
glossed over so i actually loved the
conversation with garcelle because
garcelle is right like there is
something going on where she feels
excluded for sure but then i think she
also like broke and was very vulnerable
being being like i feel excluded but i
definitely am also like holding back
because it's really hard for me to be
the only black girl in this group
and lisa reynolds was like going so hard
on garcia like we don't leave you out
you leave yourself out and then when
garcellic really explained what was
going on ugh i could have just killed
lisa like she was so oh my god fake like
getting up and hugging her like she's
just so fraudulent if i were garcelle i
would just be like yes well first of all
i that thing of like people coming
behind you behind i'm just someone who
like i can't even when erica was crying
at the dinner table at kathy hilton she
had like a tear and garcelle touched her
face to wipe it away and erica swerved
like
i don't like my face being touched i
wouldn't want my face being touchy
either so like when i see stuff like
that i i'm just like how are you just
sitting there and lisa is just so fake
and also what really was confusing to me
it's like i think they all had a
breakthrough moment
and i'm glad that garcelle like shared
and that is how you become you know
closer 100 percent you share like how
you're feeling about stuff but the women
were just like a little too happy like
they were just like this is amazing like
it's like your friend is crying and
she's been feeling this way for a really
long time like is this really so amazing
no lisa i'm telling you lisa was like
too happy and i actually think the
person who had like the most genuine
reaction was kyle
and i really appreciated like what
kyle's kyle was like i'm obviously not
happy that she's been going through this
but i'm so happy to know about it i
think that was a good way to respond
lisa was like doing a dance party that
like garcelle has been you know she's
like ourselves crying and that girl was
crying and her whole life she felt like
an outsider like that makes you happy
yeah it was just like it was a kind of
an
a lot reaction i completely agree
ultimately i think garcelle felt like
well received by their reaction and i
think that the dinner and the evening
then got off to a much better foot and
hopefully dori can just bury whatever
gripe she has no doritos
hanging onto this garcelle thing for a
story line because otherwise it's just
about her stupid dresses and like okay
so garcelle did an interview with mario
lopez and was like they're coming for me
and i'm coming for them which when
you're out promoting house i was like
that's a very non-specific fine thing to
say like you know they're coming for me
and i'm coming from them that builds up
height for the show it's not a big deal
at all so like kyle should not have
brought it up and dorit should have just
[ __ ] let it go like yeah everything
to cut everything garcelle says jeri
takes as a slight towards her or she's
just trying to hang on to this so she
can keep talking about it and it's like
if you wanted to if someone asked you
about how's the season going because
garcelle's the only one who does press
every single day because that's her job
what else should she talk about eric
it's all very peaceful erica right
because that's what everybody wants to
know so instead she made it about
herself like that's actually a nice
thing to do i thought it was a totally
fine thing to say and talk about being
blown out of proportion like yeah so
dumb so dumb and you know i'm sorry
garcelle is just spitting facts left
right and center like also lisa arena is
so up her ass to be friends again but
lisa brennan never steps in and helps
garcelle when like people are ganging up
on her ourselves just taking on a lot of
women or none she doesn't even have to
take her side but like helps mediate
anything like yeah lisa runs outside to
harry hamlin yeah it's true and then
lisa will say in her confessional that
it's because she doesn't agree with
garcelle's point of view but then it's
like
how can you have a friend who you
literally never agree with right or like
who you're always against but you're
dying to be back in their good graces
right it's like no no i'm your friend i
just i don't agree with you ever and i'm
sorry garcellus right a lot of the time
like she's a really good head on her
shoulders and she doesn't have any like
crazy alliances that like that cloud her
judgment exactly i just do think she
feels very protective of sutton and they
have a nice friendship her wheeling's
sutton around and being like i can't
believe you're doing this to me on black
history month like that was so funny so
funny they have a great friendship i
actually think they're really funny and
you know what's so crazy what this
episode highlighted it's like rina or
some or kyle was like in their
confessional like if you want to be a
friend if you want to have a friend you
have to be a friend and garcelle doesn't
do this for me and she didn't know
kyle's birthday and this that and the
other thing i think that was weird
though
okay whatever maybe like
fine she didn't know kyle's birthday but
in the whole episode there's one woman
who's in a wheelchair and it's garcelle
who's showing up to stuff that's true
every single day to make sure that she
gets to where they're going and she's
the only one being an actual friend so
in the same episode where they're saying
that she doesn't know how to be a friend
she's actually being a better friend
than any of them agreed but i did think
that birthday thing was bizarre like
just because like
kyle's famous so like you know people a
million people are posting on instagram
and i just sometimes feel like maybe
that's what garcelle was saying she
doesn't really see these women as
friends she sees him as co-workers um
and she's afraid to like let that wall
down just because of all that she's been
through and i did think that was just
bizarre like how do you not know what's
your your co-star's birthday
i don't know maybe she doesn't spend
that much time on instagram maybe she
doesn't run her on instagram like maybe
she's busy
also like i don't think she would lie
about it so she just didn't know why
didn't all the women just meet at the
hotel in del mar like why did they have
to meet at kyle's house watching that
whole ordeal was give me such bad
anxiety yeah
like such chaos yeah though the trip
looks really nice and yeah just like i
would love to do a gno to an empty hotel
no i know and like that's a great thing
about when l.a and like that's what i
always see on like oc and beverly hills
there's so many great drivable
destinations like santa barbara palm
springs del mar wherever they are lake
tahoe like oh there's a big sur like in
shadows of sunset they just went like
literally camping and it literally
looked like the mountains in like utah
like
there's a million things that's a great
thing about california like for us it's
like the jersey shore atlantic city
hamptons
like there's really not much upstate
yeah
so that looked really fun and i just
love kathy hilton like i'm sorry she
really is the gem of the season without
contributing one ounce of like energy or
drama but i do love when she does like
make her stands known and everybody just
respects it it's crazy like she'll say
like drop it and they drop it because
she's really like this wise leader yeah
and no one wants to like embarrass
themselves in front of her no and she's
not ever gonna get in tit for tat with
anyone so no one even bothers yeah she's
a queen like i'm obsessed no i totally
agree and her house is so [ __ ] nice
like the back of it is just gorgeous
and that facial although how dumb like
to waste a facial on a reiki infused
face mask like wasting money just looked
like a delightful way to spend my day
last week's episode oh that was last
week oh so i caught up and i have to say
and i know i'm late but like the
conversation that
dorite pk kyle and mauricio had about
the ankle was sending me pk is literally
i'm sorry like
the best housewife this season like
everything that comes out of his mouth
is so funny and so true
and when they're trying to rationalize
why they
wouldn't the hospital wouldn't operate
on tom's brain injury but instead his
ankle like and doritos trying to like
come up with reasons i was just dying
and i felt like maybe like when kyle and
dorit were cooking in the kitchen like
mauricio and pk like went out and smoked
pot because they were like giving me
vibes of like people who were stoned and
it was that's so very likely it's very
likely yeah yeah so funny it was really
funny and kyle like wanted to die
because kyle's really trying to stay on
erica's good side like just in case but
now in real time like i don't think that
that's there oh i do no apparently kyle
said i mean erica said she only went
into the reunion with one friend yeah
but like right before the reunion
remember they were all in mexico on the
boats
but things have changed since then i
believe good and the women are on the
outs and even like so they're gonna look
really [ __ ] stupid for what they did
this year five went to john malacanam's
concert and erica wasn't there and it
was in vegas right and she was in vegas
opening sushi samba oh man literally
you're right
all the wait was well it's not five fab
five renault wasn't there it was just
teddy dorit and kyle okay maybe rena was
you know busy busy and then two other
people but usually erica would have been
invited to yeah of course and she was in
vegas so like after she opened the
restaurant she could have just gone to
the concert they all went to a john
mellencam concert and honestly he
brought the housewives on stage and it
looked so fun like that why couldn't
teddy have brought that energy when she
was on the show like a john mellencamp
concert that they all go to and film
would it be great for john
great for the cougs is that his band
the cougars john mellencamp and
it's the hold up cougar sounds right no
i'm like pretty sure like yeah because
he's john cougar mellencamp right or
just make that up no that makes sense
hold on teddy just posted it i was
looking right before him
what's your the cougs yeah okay cool
and i just like kind of love like john
like being a house husband it's like why
don't we get any of that when teddy was
on
she probably didn't want to be like
known for that now she's probably well
now she's known for nothing so
right well no she's known for being
fired which sucks yeah but it seems like
she's enjoying her life yeah it does and
like her i don't think she liked being a
housewife i don't i don't think she
could take the pressure people just
didn't like her like and in the
beginning they didn't like her for no
reason which is like really hard to deal
with like when you're just a nice person
and people don't like you and you're
just like not coming off well it's just
a lot i think she has a nice life like
she doesn't need that so i i'm glad it
worked out and i'm glad her and um
kyle are still friends exactly that was
like a real friendship exactly i think
it's all good there me too so all in all
it wasn't like a crazy episode but um
they did just film the reunion and i'm
very much looking forward to it i do
kind of wish they had waited it's like
the last possible minute right because
now we have like this tom footage that's
right
honestly they should bring back the live
reunion
they should and it should be like an
all-day affair oh my god that would be
crazy because they filmed for like 12 13
hours for the regular reunion and they
only air like two and a half hours i
know but
i mean i'm just saying like real houses
in miami did it and they weren't even
interesting
yeah but it wasn't
good
i would love that so that's a tv recap
and i believe that's our show is that
correct
can you confirm our show do what do you
think
he said affirmative yeah thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast millennial morning show where we
deliver the facts by stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places where we
listen to the podcast find us morning
shows leave a five star review about a
beautiful
sunday and smart we are congratulations
if you have made it to the end of the
episode you are a part of the society
season two and you are a true toaster so
if you are here let us know that you've
made it to the end of the episode by
leaving a comment on our most recent
instagram and have that comment be the
emoji of the electric guitar for the
cougs for the cougs yes okay love you
guys have a great day we'll see you
tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
bye